We developed the original Sunshine app
in parallel with the development of
material design in Android.
For that reason the design already
incorporates some material concepts.
We're going to take the design
a bit farther in that direction
with the help of a support library.
While Sunshine functions on phones and
tablet's of all sizes
it wouldn't come close to be considered
a tablet optimized application.
Material design could help us here.
We can take advantage of patterns
that add extra space into and
around our layouts to make things
feel more natural on these devices.
The new support library makes it easy
to bring some material design to our
application.
It implements toolbars and
makes it generally easy to bring vibrant
material colors to our application.
Finally, we're going to add motion and
dimension to our application.
Some of this will only apply
to newer Android releases, but
we'll make sure that the experience
is good on all of our devices.